معنا من بلده سعاره داخل الخط الاخضر
مراسله اهل الجزيره جيفارا البديري جيفارا
اهلا بك كيف هي الاجواء حيث انت اذا
اجواء فرح رغم التنقيص الذي قامت به سلطات
الاسرائيليه
بالافراج عن كريم يونس فجاه دون السماح
لاهله لل الفلسطينيين الذين احتجدوا امام
سجن هداريم لاستقبال حيث تم نقله عبر
سياره مخابرات اسرائيليه من داخل السجن
الى محطه للحافلات ولكن كريم يونس الان
بعد اربعين عاما يتنسم الحريه مشاعر
مختلطه يرى الشمس دون شباك لاول مره منذ
40 عاما معنى الان الاسير المحرر عميد
الاسرى الفلسطينيين احد اقدم الاسرى في
العالم حمد الله على السلامه
مشاعر مختلطه ولكن سنبدا ما الذي حدث في
الساعات الاولى يعني ساعات ما قبل الفجر
اقدمت قوه من من الشرطه واقتحموا القسم
واخرجوني قالوا لي هسه انت طالع وانت
نحضر حالك انا اسريت انه يعني ادخل على
الحمام
لكن قالوا لي بسرعه قديش بتقدر تطلعوني
على اساس قالوا لي انت مروح من خلال
الرفقه من الشرطه لكن تفاجات انه جاب
سياره ويطلعوني في السياره
بخمس دقائق دخلت في مكان هيك يمكن همم
طريق جانبيه
كمان يعني ترجع سياره في ظهر سياره
سياره يعني بدون منزل على الارض حتى
وبعمليه وكانها شبه عسكريه اييه لدرجه اني
انا استغربته واحتجيت على هذا
اعطوك في النهايه في النهايه ادوني امناتي
واوراقي وكل ما كان معي
بنات منذ 40 سنه همم ودوني بطاقه وقالوا
لي شايف هذيك المحطه
قالوا لي بتروح هناك وبتركب في الباص
وبتروح لحالك كنت عارف وين انت همم سالت
الشباب
الفلسطينيين
وسالتهم قالوا له احنا موجودين في مفرق
في محطه الباصات المركزيه طلبته من واحد
تلفون واتصلت اخواني وهمم
قالوا لي انتظر واحنا خلال نصف ساعه نكون
عندك وكلت لهم انا بطلع هيك بره بريه
المحطه
اخوي حكيم
همم ترى الشمس لاول مره منذ 40 عاما تمشي
على الاسف- الاسفلت والشارع همم في بيت
همم الذي حرمت منه لاربعين عاما
ما الذي تشعر به الان الان
بمشي على الاسفلت لاول مره من 40 سنه
ويمكن كل واحد بيقدر يقدر شو المشاعر هاي
اللي انا مش قادر اعبر عنها انا بشوف
الخضار وبشوف ال- الشجر وبشوف كذا اللي
قبل بكيت اشوف بس جدران اسمنت اليوم بشوف
قاعد شجر وبشوف خضار وبشوف حشب وبشوف
بالاسفلت ودخلت على دوره
حديد ولا مره يعني اول مره
انا قاعد
الطريقه غريبه
كان بعيد عن كل هذه الاشياء
على الارض
ليس بالامر الطبيعي ولكن في لحظات الاخيره
بقيت التهديدات بان لا تقام احتفالات بلغت
العائله بعدم رفع الاعلام الفلسطينيه بعدم
وضع هتافات بعدم وجود اغاني ولكن الان بعد
ان خرجت وتحررت ما هي الرساله التي خرجت
بها
يعني يمكن حوالي 10 ايام
جاءت همم او همم مسؤول المنطقه مسؤول
المخابرات الاسرائيليه في منطقه وادي عاره
وقبلني وهمم في البدايه حاول طلع بتهديدات
وانه في اليوم حكومه بن كثير بس مدرج قلت
له لا تهددنيش لابس بنزين ولا عصابات
عن اللي بدنا اياه قال لي ممنوع يكون
احتفالات هذا الشيء مش انت بتقرروا قال لي
فش قاعات قلت له للاسف يعني لاصحاب
القاعات رفضوا تاجير قاعات وهمم احتفل في
وفي في بيتنا وعند اخي وبين اهلي وهذا
الشيء بتقدرش تمنعني قال لي ممنوع كل اللي
بدك اياه سويه واعلى ما بخل لك اركبوه
الوحده الفلسطينيه هكذا يصفك الاسرى ويصفك
الفلسطينيون بدايه هل تحمل رساله من داخل
السجون الاسرائيليه من الاسرى ومن الرساله
الان لفلسطين كلها
بعبرها عن همم احترامي وتقديري
وتحياتي الى كل الابناء شعبنا في كل
الاماكن تواجدهم في الضفه وفي غزه وفي
الشتات وفي الداخل الكل الكل اليوم يقف
يكفي واحده من اجل فلسطين وشعب عظيم يناضل
100 سنه في سبيل الحريته هو تقرير مصيره
وهذا شيء يستحق التحيه وتعظيم سلام تعظيم
سلام لشعبنا منكم والى كل ابناء شبابنا في
كل مكان رساله الاسرى دائما كانت اولا هم
كمان بحيوا شعبنا واحتضانه لقضيه الاسرى
ووقوف شعبنا مع الاسراء
عنداتهم
وكذلك الامر بحيوا بحيوا مش بس نضال ابناء
شعبنا بحيوا كمان همم وبيدعوا الى الوحده
الوطنيه لانه بالسجن تعلمنا
بالسجن تعلمنا دائما انه
وحدتنا او قوتنا في وحدتنا والاسرى اليوم
عزائي رغم اني تركتهم كل واحد يحمل يعني
حقيقي ثقيله على كتافه
والموت يمشي معهم الا انه همم تركتهم
موحدين وهذا عزاءنا ان هم وحدين وبيعملوا
من كل ابناء شعبنا بالوحده لانه بالسجن
تعلمنا انه الوحده الوطنيه الانتصار وهم
اليوم موحدين في وجهه هجمات بن كبير
وتهديدات وللاسرى اولا لارجاعهم الى سنوات
السبعينات وان شاء الله انهم قادرين
كالجبال ان يقف بوجه هذا الطاووس والحفاظ
على حقوقهم هم سيخذون معركه معركه حياه او
موت معركه حريه معركه يمكن ان تستندد كل
ابناء شعبنا في كل الاماكن تواجدوا للوقوف
معهم وحتى تغيير الواقع في فلسطين ان شاء
الله
وانا يعني
بهذه المناسبه وخاصه لاخواني في في شبكه
الجزيره همم احنا دائما يعني قديش الاخت
شيرين ابو عقلي عزت علينا وكانت نموذج في
العطاء وهي كانت صوره فلسطين وصوت فلسطين
وسفيره فلسطين في كل مكان وفي كل بيت مش
بس في فلسطين والعالم العربي وانما في
العالم وهمم اللي بيحاولوا اليوم يكرروا
يمكن همم اللي صار مع الاخت شيرين القتل
العمد هو استهداف لانه اليوم احنا بنشعرش
انه الشخص هو المستهدف وان من المقاومه هي
المستهدفه
والنضال هو المستهدف وهم يستهدف
همم ابناء شعبنا لترويضهم و ايصال الرساله
انه اي مقاومه يمكن ان تقرب حذف هؤلاء
الناس بكل من ناطر كل من ناضل كل من ناضل
من اجل فلسطين ما كانش مستهدفه بشكل شخصي
وانما نضال هو المستهدف في هجمه ومنهجي
لترويض هذا الشعب هم بدهم يانا شعب خانق
خنوع همم مطيع همم زي ما كان ماشي ديان
همم 68 سنجعل من هؤلاء ادوات ادميه قيعه
وبدهم ايانه حتى بين وسكريين كيف كيف كيف
قال للسنوات
لكن احنا بنقول لن نكون لاحد طبيعي
الحمد لله على السلامه
الشهيده الحركه الاسيره الاخير وهم كثر
لكن الاخ ناصر ابو حميد الذي توفي اييي
ليس استشهد قبل فتره قصيره جدا تحيه الى
والدته الى عائلته واحنا بنعمل انه باقي
الاسرى يخرجوا مرفوعين الراي وليس
الاحتجاج وتخيلوا انه حتى الاسير يتم
احتجاز جثته ما بين ما ينهي محكومته وهي
اسرائيلي وهذا سلوك اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
الحمد لله على السلامه يا الاسير المحرر
كريم يونس اقدم الاسرى الفلسطينيين الذي
بالطبع همم خاض منذ اعتقاله اصعب واطول
حكم واصعب ايضا تحقيق في اقبيه الزنازين
خاض كل الاضرابات مع الاسرى الان يبدو
تحدي جديد هنا من الاهالي الذين تم
تهديدهم بعدم رفع الاعلام ترديد الشعارات
والهتافات الى حد الامر ان بعض المصادر
الاسرائيليه قالت ان وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي المتطرف لتماد بين كبير طلب من
الشرطه الاسرائيليه بمنع اي احتفالات
بالاسير كريم يونس الذي الان رغم كل شيء
يرفع على الاكتاف كما نرى هنا سينتقل الى
الخيمه التي نصبتها العائله خلف المنزل
لان كل القاعات تلقى التهديد مباشر من
مبارات الاسرائيليه بعدم فتح ابوابها
لاستقبال الاسير كاري المحرر كريم يونس
وهو بالطبع عضو اللجنه المركزيه لحركه فتح
وطلق منذ ساعات الصباح اتصالات من عمداء
الاسرى لتحيته وايضا من كبار المسؤولين
الفلسطينيين واتصال ايضا من
الرئيس الفلسطيني اذا نحن بانتظار يوم
طويل قد يكون فقط شيء اخير سفيان بالنسبه
للصحفيين يعني اعتبروا ان هذا اليوم هو
ايضا مفرح لهم بان ينقلوا خبر على الهواء
بعد عام دام جدا ان ينقل خبر مفرح وهو
تحرر الاسير كريم يونس نحن ايضا بعد اشهر
بانتظار تحرر ابني عمه ماهر يونس الذي
ايضا كان معه في ذات العمليه العسكريه
وايضا حكم عليه بالسجن لاربعين عاما
الاسير المحاضر وهنيئا له الحريه